[Music]
hi
grandma i brought you flowers you look
beautiful thank you
i brought you a challah like i'd like to
piece off harley yeah
okay give it to me when i was little i
thought that everybody's grandparent was
a holocaust survivor i didn't understand
how unusual
it was i am one of the last ones yes
so grandma will tell some stories today
in your little village in poland what
was your first sign that something was
seriously wrong
well the way we're talking will be a war
will not be a war and all of a sudden on
a beautiful day we stayed in the
backyard
the aeroplanes came from germany
and they start shooting they start
catching
jews in the streets and shooting them
and that's when the trouble starts
you were only a teenager at this time
yes and your whole family had to move
out of your home
and you had to move into a ghetto which
was like an area designated for jews
yes did you think this will pass we are
always living with hope
we always thought maybe in a month or in
a day or in a week
the war will end and we'll be free
and that's how he lived
every few minutes
[Music]
came a truck and we take away the people
and over there in the the cubes from the
for the chicken whatever were my sisters
two beautiful children
she hid her children in the chicken
coops
yes and she was a delight so auschwitz
so i went over to that german
and i said to him he should let lose my
sister
let my sister go my sister is young
you can she can work she's good she's
everything
but grandma i also want to this was very
very important
i saved my sister and i saved my life
so i just want to make it clear because
this is a very difficult part of our
family story
we don't know what happened to your
niece and nephew right
they were hidden in the chicken coop and
that's the last thing you know about
these babies right
yes beautiful babies by blonde curly
hair
you got a report that your brothers were
last seen
on april 27 1945 which was just
at the beginning of the liberation so
you thought they were going to just a
few days
unfortunately i live i find out a few
years later
they took the whole group they put them
in a barn
and they burned them alive
that is the story of my three brothers
grandma i want to ask you about the
moment
of liberation every year when the spring
comes
and it gets warm i'm happy
i am happy that i survived
[Music]
here is something that i have always
wondered about you
almost your entire family was murdered
by the nazis you lived through terrible
trauma
but for most of your life and my entire
life
you have been one of the
people i know your partner has once told
me that i always smile
everybody suffered from the same tragedy
and we try to to survive to be alive
but there was nothing to we couldn't go
back
yeah you only had to go forward
[Music]
grandma i know you watch the news a lot
we have all heard more reports
of anti-semitism in this country my
friend told me
they had an one a plot six million is
not enough
yeah and things like that
so it's it's weird like an oven
and a fire and i and i
and i felt very very bad about this
and because i went through this and it's
shocking it's something you never
expected to see in the united states
again
[Music]
grandma we have a really big family now
what do you want your
great-grandchildren who are
being born now to know about you
whatever you know
just tell them everything yes i didn't
do nothing wrong
jodie cantor boy jody that was so tender
and so loving and i think
what a blessing for you to be able to
have that conversation with your
grandmother
the the boy the relationship between the
two of you is very very clear to see
but i'm curious about this well go ahead
jody go ahead
no i just wanted to thank you for
sharing it you know that
we all have the responsibility of
sharing these stories and it's just
really
um it's this is a private family story
and it's an honor
it's an honor for it to be on the show
and i
brought you one more thing because
there's a kind of
unusual document in my family that i
wanted to show you
you know there's a debate about
reparations in this country now and a
lot of people say that
they're impractical they're impossible
to implement
but you know my grandmother and that
sort of stable
happy life you see her having is
possible
in part because she actually gets
reparations she gets hundreds of dollars
each month from the german government
and i i brought you
one of the statements so that people
could actually see
that this is a real thing yeah but i'm
i'm so fascinated why she can be so
sunny
considering all that she has seen to see
the death of her brothers the little
nieces and the nephews that
clearly didn't make it i marvel at
people like that and i'm so glad that
you brought the story to us i'm very
fascinated
by your grandmother now and i heard that
you took her to get vaccinated jody in
january
what was that like
you know look at that picture i was so
worried during coronavirus that after my
grandmother who's kind of a survivor
among survivors
and has survived everything i was so
worried gail that this
degrading isolating pandemic that we've
all
lived through was going to take her and
when i took her to get vaccinated it was
like it just represented life
gail it just represented like my
grandmother
you know survived the nazis and now she
is
going to survive this and we are going
to get
uh you know some of our some of our
elderly through this
safely jody it's anthony i find the
reparations thing so interesting because
the rep
the check itself is essentially an
admission by the german government that
we wronged you
uh and so in that sense i it's a very
powerful
it's not just money it's a powerful
statement in its own way
how long has your grandmother been
getting it and and and has it helped her
emotionally in some way
well she's gotten it i think since the
50s or the 60s it's always been a part
of my family it's part of the family
story
that you know the the language i wish
you could see is so
spooky they come in german and it says
forsaden which means for harm
which is you know just these words hint
at the kind of universe of loss
that she endured but when when we taped
that interview last week i asked her i
said grandma can you explain
how these reparations have helped you
and therefore me
live a more stable life and recover from
this trauma
and she said jody the money is mine and
what she meant is this is not charity
she was slave labor she was in these
forced labor camps
and she's saying these were the wages i
was never
paid when my life was taken for me and i
was forced to work
are you allowed to say how much the
reparations are
yeah it's uh it's in the high three
figures okay it's in the high
it's in the high three figures uh per
month and so when you
when you think about that month after
month right yeah no it adds up jody
thank you for
giving us a lot of money we've got to go
but such a powerful story thanks for
being with us
and thanks for sharing it we'll be right
back